all right hello everyone welcome to
another episode of Science and
Technology Q&A for kids and others I was
off for a week or so going to various
kinds of events um but I am back so
let's see first question we have here
from
Nuno um has to do with dark matter and
asking is it possible that individual
particles have a Halo of dark matter
like galaxies do well let's talk a
little bit about what dark matter
is
so when we look in the night sky for
example examp Le we see lots of stars
which from which we see light and the
stars have all kinds of nuclear
reactions going on that are producing
energy producing light we get to see the
light but the question is how much
matter how much stuff is there out in
the universe altogether and we can get
some idea of that by looking at the
effect on the orbits of other
things of
what the what the orbits of things look
like so for example if we see that
something is kind of circling around
some area then we know that there has to
be mass in that area to keep the thing
moving in its orbit and the mass is
what's needed to generate the gravity
that will keep the thing going around
its orbit if there wasn't a mass there
the thing would just keep going and
there wasn't any Gravity the thing would
just keep going in a straight line
rather than being curled up in an orbit
so you can kind of measure the the mass
that's present in a particular region by
looking at kind of the gravitational
effect of that mass and the thing that's
been known for about 100 years now is
that if you look at galaxies like ours
that uh where there are stars kind of
orbiting around the center of the Galaxy
that the our galaxy is rotating I think
it's
every 150 million years maybe for our
galaxy that it it does a rotation on its
axis and um the uh uh and that means
that the stars are all sort of orbiting
around the the center now the question
is from the way those orbits work one
can work out how much mass there is
altogether in the Galaxy it turns out
the mass in the galaxy is like 10 times
the mass that we can account for by
looking at the stars we see in the
Galaxy so there's been kind of a big
mystery of what is the what is usually
referred to as dark matter the matter
that we can't see as stars that's not
producing energy not producing light
what is that dark matter that has a
gravitational effect but doesn't have an
effect on uh the that doesn't show up as
actual stars that produce light and so
on and there are some more extreme cases
of this where for example two Galaxies
have collided and there see there seems
to be sort of a lump of stuff in the
middle that we can't see that is not a
luminous matter that still has a
gravitational effect
so it seems like there's there's
something that's making gravity but not
making stars and light and so
on so there's been a long time question
what is it is it for example stars that
uh you know is it little is it you know
for example uh all kinds of you know
planets that escaped from solar systems
stars that weren't quite big enough I
mean basically if you have a bunch of
matter and it's sufficiently big then
the kind of gravitational effect of that
matter on itself will pull it in at such
a so so hard that eventually the nuclei
of of atoms in it will get pushed close
together and eventually they'll fuse and
that produces energy and that produces
nuclear fusion energy in the same way
that that happens in the Sun and when as
soon as you get something which is I
don't know what it is maybe 10th the
size of the sun maybe a little bit
smaller than that not sure
um the the uh some some some definite
size somewhat smaller than the sun it's
inevitable that there'll be enough
pressure produced by sort of the gravity
of the thing on itself to force nuclear
fusion to occur and to turn it into a
star so at least if if it's made of
ordinary matter that's what will happen
so there are lots of theories about what
Dark Matter might be from traditional
things that just don't show up as as
stars to things like maybe the little
black holes well you can kind of see
these things where the where the mass is
concentrated in big lumps you kind of
expect to see kind of the effect of that
big lump of matter that big lump of mass
going in front of other things you don't
see such effects you don't appear to so
that means people tend to think that
dark matter is something more diffuse
more spread out and so on and uh so
people and there's also one of of the
things that is seems to be the case
about dark matter is that if it is made
of particles for example that the
particles don't have a a high
temperature they're not the particles
are not bouncing around and uh hitting
each other because they don't the the
the expectation is that they don't
really react with
uh uh with other kinds of matter if they
did we would see effects other than
gravitational effects from whatever this
is and there sort of question of the
does the Dark Matter interact with
itself but not with ordinary matter
that's another possibility my own
suspicion about these things is that the
idea that dark matter is made of
particles is just not right um the
analogy that I am fond of giving is that
in the 1800s when people wondered what
is heat heat is this thing that can
affect an object and heat can flow from
one object to another and people kind of
said well if it is Flowing from one
thing to another the only thing it could
be is a fluid like a waterlike thing
that would be some kind of fluid that
kind of just goes inside an object and
makes it hot and can flow to other
objects to make them hot too and that
was what was called caloric or caloric
fluid and that was how people what
people believed heat was until basically
the beginning of the 20th century and it
became clear in the end that what heat
is is microscopic motions of molecules
now you had to know that molecules
existed which people didn't know in with
any degree of certainty in the be until
the beginning of the 20th century but
the the fact that heat isn't kind of a
fluid that flows from one material to
another heat really is a feature of the
microscopic structure of materials so it
is my suspicion that dark matter is a
feature of the microscopic feature
microscopic structure of space but
that's a view that requires that you
imagine that space is discrete which is
what we think is now is true um and it
requires that there is some feature of
space that is associated with this kind
of different thing that produces
gravitational effect but doesn't uh
produce sort of a particle like effect
now
you know the so what might that be how
does that work well the the the prompt
here the question here um the
uh uh had to do with whether there's
Dark Matter associated with particles so
particles like electrons quarks photons
and so on these are all what are usually
considered Elementary particles they're
usually considered particles that don't
have any inner substructure the an
electron for example so far as we know
is infinitely small it has when there is
an electron it has the effect of
changing the electromagnetic field
around it it can produce virtual
particle anti-particle pairs it can it
has a whole coat of sort of quantum
activity around the the electron but the
electron itself seems to have zero size
well that's been the traditional theory
for the last 100 years or so uh in our
model of physics that really isn't
correct an electron is made like
everything else as a feature of the
structure of space effectively it's made
from this graph this hyper graph uh that
connects the individual elements the
individual atoms of space so what is an
electron well our guess is that an
electron is some kind of kind of
topological feature of all these
Connections in the structure of space so
the analog that I tend to use for this
is in a fluid which has a bunch of
molecules bouncing around underneath
there are features like vortices edies
in the fluid that involve lots of
molecules and they involve kind of this
this thing where they're all sort of
going around someplace and you can't
kind of they they can't uh just sort of
all the the the things going one way on
one side the other way on the other side
they can't just sort of cancel each
other out there's that sort of
topological defect in the middle that
prevents them from just kind of decaying
away by canceling each other out and so
our guess is that particles are features
of the structure of space that are sort
of tangles in this network that are
Tangles you can't easily get rid of and
so what might those Tangles be like
actually one serious possibility is that
those Tangles are very much like black
holes black holes are are places where
the structure of space or more
specifically the structure of the the
the graph of causal relations in space
and time um has has certain features and
I think um the
uh the way that um uh that that that and
in particular it has an event horizon
which is a place where kind of effects
can go from the outside in but not from
the inside out it's like black hole we
living outside the black hole only get
to kind of know what's
happening outside the black hole and for
us the black hole just looks like this
one sort of integrated thing that
doesn't have any substructure and so
that's a little bit like these particles
it's kind of like the electron from the
outside well all electrons look the same
they they seem to have some definite
sort of external structure what they
might be like inside whether they're
even all the same inside is is unclear
but there's may be an analogy between
black holes and uh uh and and things
like electrons so a question then would
be okay actually a good question is
whether there is dark matter uh sort of
collected around a black hole the dark
matter has a gravitational effect does
it does it get pulled in to the
gravitational uh uh to to the gravity of
ordinary matter the answer presumably is
yes um what the effect of that is around
a black hole I don't know it's a good
question I mean I think we're actually
getting quite close in our physics
project to being able to simulate gravit
gravitational phenomena in enough detail
that we should see things that are
potentially related to Dark Matter so
that will be an interesting thing in
fact just last week we got some nice
sort of videos simulations of two tiny
black hole in our models uh merging and
what what's most notable in these in
these videos is that the structure of
Space is really wiggling around a lot
but yet there's this kind of region that
is associated with black hole that's
pretty stable even though space is kind
of wobbling around all over the place
and these are very very tiny black holes
so these are black holes that might be
uh you know a trillion trillion trillion
trillion trillion trillion trillion
trillionth roughly of a meter across um
so the uh very tiny black holes but even
a very tiny black hole is thought to
have many of the same properties as
whatever big black hole you might find
that came from a collapsed
star so at least we seem to have a hope
of of reproducing kind of the structure
of SpaceTime the structure of matter
particularly matter that corresponds to
black holes uh sort of accurately enough
that we might see the effects of dark
matter and that's sort of an interesting
thing that could arise in our physics
project sort of any day now um and uh I
think the question of what happens with
quotes ordinary particles not black
holes we still don't really know what
ordinary particles are like although
they may be closer to black holes than
we think so there's a bunch that is not
known there and that's something I'm
hoping to uh to be able to answer fairly
soon
um let's see
oh boy all sorts of questions
here
um okay Brady asked how is antimatter
made in the lab and what makes it so
difficult to
produce okay so first point is what is
antimatter so a proton for example is a
particle that has a positive charge
charge of plus one unit of charge the
electron has a charge of minus one unit
of charge so that means when you combine
a proton an electron and an atom proton
is plus one electron is minus one the
atom will be neutral if it has if it has
let's say single proton single electron
like the most common form of
hydrogen okay but it is a it is
something that was discovered in the
1930s that to every particle like a
proton or or an electron there is an
antiparticle and the antiparticle is
basically exactly the same as the
particle except that its charge is the
opposite all its charges actually
there's other kinds of charge than
electric charge are the opposite of what
they are for the particles so there is
an antiproton which has the same mass as
a proton the same other characteristics
it's spin it's whatever but it has minus
the charge of the proton similarly for
an electron there is an antiparticle of
an electron called a positron that has a
charge of plus one unit instead of the
minus one unit for the electron but
otherwise so far as we can tell the
positron and the electron are identical
they have the same mass same spin
they're identical in every way except
for these opposite charges now one of
the things that's a big surprise in a
sense is you might think oh you the
universe must be symmetrical between
matter and antimatter how could one have
one out over the other and in fact when
I was younger when I was a kid maybe uh
well now half a century ago I suppose
almost um it really wasn't clear the the
obvious assumption was that the Universe
would be sort of equal amounts of matter
and antimatter and maybe that there
would be in fact some of my earliest
personal research projects involved
trying to figure out whether the
universe could separate into regions of
matter and regions of antimatter but it
turns out that doesn't seem to be what's
happening it seems instead that the
universe is a tiny excess of matter over
antimatter so in the very early universe
one one there were about out of every
100 million protons and antiprotons for
example there was one extra proton and
so the end result is the protons and
antiprotons annihilate each other and
you get left over with this residue of
protons and as opposed to antiprotons so
the whole universe seems to be made
basically matter rather than antimatter
and how that happens is still somewhat
unclear because it the the most common
theories I in fact worked on these
things back in the beginning of the
1980s around 1979 1980 trying to figure
out how this works it's a very
interesting exercise in physics um it
relies on uh at least one kind of effect
that we don't haven't really for sure
seen in the lab we think it it happens
that way it has to do with the fact that
particles can decay in a way that uh
they are they violate certain symmetries
to the point where there can end up
being more particles than antiparticles
made in the decay of those particular
particles so whether that really happens
that way we as I say don't have lab
observation we know we know some
particles have the feature that they
Decay differently into particles than
antiparticles um but
uh and um we don't know uh whether the
particles you would need to account for
the excess of matter over antimatter in
the universe uh exists they're much more
the the particles that are like more
than a trillion times heavier than a
proton we haven't observed such things
yet um but that's sort of the hypothesis
about how that works but so there isn't
much kind of it's not like the universe
not like we just have to go to the next
door Galaxy not that that's easy to do
but that we discover the next door
Galaxy is made of antimatter it's not um
so how do we make antimatter well what
happens is
that particles can be produced in pairs
so when you make you can make a proton
antiproton pair essentially you can make
that out of sort of pure energy what is
pure energy well you can have a couple
of photons for example you can have
these photons interact with each other
and these two photons can produce for
example an electron positron pair you
can also have there are all kinds of
ways to produce electron positron pairs
that quite often produced when you have
a particle that's going fast through a
material then as it interacts with the
nuclei of atoms there you can get pair
production you can get uh production of
of essentially sort of photons or
photons that are associated with the
forces that hold electrons into atoms
electromagnetic forces um it's a little
bit more complicated here it involves
these things called virtual photons
which are photons that kind of live only
a very very short time and have somewhat
different characteristics from ordinary
photons or can but in any case the the
end result is it's possible to produce
electron positron pairs U without much
difficulty actually um as soon as you
have as soon as you're sort of pumping
energy into a material um Beyond you
have to pump enough energy that it is
more than the effective energy
associated with the mass of an electron
plus the mass of a of a positron and you
know there's this famous formula eal mc2
and that tells you sort of how much
energy corresponds to the rest mass of a
particle so if you if you have enough
energy if you have energy equal to the
mass of the electron plus the mass of
the positron that energy can cause an
electron and a positron to be produced
the energy is in the form of photons for
example okay so that's how you
potentially can produce electron
positron pairs you can do that by for
example accelerating electrons uh for
example with an electric field um you
can just accelerate electrons and crash
them into some target of some material
and inside that material the electron as
it interacts with the atoms can produce
electron positron Pairs and in general
you get a shower of electron positron
pairs as each of the electrons and
positrons then produces more electrons
and positrons until they until their
energy goes down below the point where
they it corresponds to twice the mass of
the electron or mass of the electron
plus mass of the positon at which point
pair production can no longer
occur but so the the proton is 1800
times heavier than the electron so you
need a lot more energy to produce proton
antiproton pairs than electron positron
pairs but in a particle accelerator you
can get that kind of energy a particle
accelerator works by for example
accelerating protons that could be
electrons to uh High energies and then
you take those electrons and for example
you crash them into a Target made of
lead or something like this some some
material and uh if the energies are high
enough you can get the production of a
proton antiproton pair okay so that's
all well and good one of the problems is
it's a very violent act producing
something like a proton antiproton pair
lots of energy has to go in and these
two the proton and antiproton come out
but typically when they come out they'll
have quite a lot of momentum they'll be
going in some random different direction
and the main difficulty in getting sort
of a bottle of antimatter is to kind of
calm the antiprotons down they're
produced and they're produced going off
in you know close to the speed of light
in some particular direction so you have
to kind kind of catch them and bottle
them up and make them lose energy but
lose energy without interacting to the
point where they can be destroyed where
for example if the antiproton meets a
proton then it'll just get annihilated
and turn into pure energy or photons
eventually photons and electrons and so
on eventually um so you kind of have to
be able to sort of chill out the
antiprotons cool down the
antiprotons um without them interacting
with anything and essentially the way
you do that is to use electromagnetic
fields use magnetic fields and so on
because it uh although that is an
interaction every time the the sort of
the antiproton is kicked by the magnetic
field that is an interaction with a
virtual Photon but those interactions do
not cause the antiproton to like
annihilate or anything like that they
just are something where Photon comes in
antiproton sort of changes Direction
maybe another Photon comes out but but
it's still an antiproton there so the
the Big Challenge tends to be to sort of
get the antiprotons in a form where you
can use them in a magnetic bottle or
something like that if you have a if you
had something which was an actual
material substance made of atoms which
have protons in them then these
antiprotons would immediately end up
annihilating with those those atoms so
the only thing you can do is sort of
hold them electromagnetically in a place
and that was just difficult to do so the
the the number of kind of bottled up
antiprotons that you can get is not very
large and and people have studied a lot
the sort of anti-atoms and things and
for example it's only was discovered
well I don't know a few decades ago now
that anti-atoms do fall under Gravity
just the same way that atoms fall under
Gravity so in other words the it is true
that the force of gravity operates in
the same way on a proton as it does on
an antiproton you know the electrical
forces because the antiproton has the
opposite charge from from a proton as
negative of the charge of the proton
electrical forces operate on opposite
ways on protons and antiprotons but
gravitational forces force of gravity
acts the same way not obvious that will
be true but that is what's true and that
tells one something about how gravity
Works relative to our electromagnetism
works the the uh the sort of the fancy
statement is the particle that is
responsible for electromagnetic forces
the photon has a spin of one unit and
the particle the graviton that's
associated with gravitational forces has
a spin of two units and that difference
between the one and the two is what
leads to this phenomenon that
uh uh protons and antiprotons behave
oppositely under electromagnetism but
behave the same way under Gravity that's
just the sort of fancy versions of it
um let's
see uh so that's the basic answer that
that it's difficult to make a bottle of
antimatter just because the ways you
make antimatter and you're making it one
particle at a time but you can make
quite large numbers of these particles
um it's just hard to kind of cool it
down and and sort of collect it in a
bottle
um
let's
see gosh Carol is asking about my
perspective on smart glasses with AI
assistant um is that the future of
smartphones you
know this question of of how we humans
interface to
technology is an interesting one I mean
we have a certain number of appendages
for interacting with technology our
fingers are a really good one and uh uh
the those are that's a way we can put
input into technology how do we get
things from technology well you know
there are our eyes and for us our
species our eyes are the highest
bandwidth way the highest uh amount of
information can get sort of understood
by our eyes relative to other sens so
like we have 10 million nerve fibers
going from our eyes to our brain for
hearing we only have 50,000 for smell we
have even much less than that uh for
dogs for example it it it works
differently that their their smell uh
apparatus is uh noses basically are um
have lots more nerve fibers relative to
uh their ears or eyes and um so for them
you know smells an important thing for
for humans there sort of you know there
are other things like this the total
surface of the skin has lots of uh
uh lots of receptors I think small I
think small compared to the eyes but
still quite large um and we haven't
really you know we haven't quite got uh
you know covered ourselves with little
actuators where sort of every every inch
of skin can be used as sort of input
from technology I'm not sure that would
really work very well but
so you know our eyes are a good source
here and um then the question is well
we're using our eyes what are we looking
at and sort of for a while the main
thing you would look at that would
interface with technology is a screen uh
you know a big screen in front of you
held vertically so to speak then there
were smartphones and it turned out
having that portable screen even though
it's much smaller than the screen you
can get sort of in front of you um is a
convenient form of of uh uh of
interaction and the fact that you can
kind of have a keyboard on the screen
and so on is um uh is interesting I mean
I have to say it surprised me that
people you know you can see these movies
in hugely high resolution it's really
impressive and then people actually are
perfectly happy watching them on their
phones now phones at this point have
very uh large number of pixels but there
still very small and they they occupy a
small field of view for us humans
because one of the issues is when you
look out into the world there's the
question of of sort of what's the
maximum angle that you can see on either
side I think it's I think it's 140
degrees if I remember right is is the
total sort of amount that humans can see
including their peripheral vision if
they if it was 180 degrees you'd be able
to see off to the side you know like a
like a horse or something which has eyes
on the on the sides of its head and so
it's um
uh it's able to you know it can it can
see um it can see more around itself I
mean it's kind of like the uh you know
the self-driving cars that have kind of
eyes on their sides as well as sort of
the big eye on top so to speak I mean
those aren't ordinary eyes those are lar
devices well for depending on what what
kind of self-driving car it is but this
this notion that you can um that you
have you know what's your field of view
anyway people have been happy
surprisingly happy with with smartphones
which have a very small field of view
you're looking at very small fraction of
of the angle that you could potentially
see so sort of a Coming Attraction is
all of these various virtual reality
augmented reality uh systems from
different companies that purport to have
something where you sort of put it on
your head and then it allows you to uh
to have things which are head-mounted
displays where where the display moves
as you turn your head and uh for example
if if you're looking at virtual reality
one of the big issues is as you turn
your head you can tell from the sort of
accelerometers in your ears that you're
turning your head but does the scene
that you see in the virtual reality
display does it move with your head and
it's been quite hard to get the scene to
move sort of at immediately as you turn
your head and not to have a delay of
some number of hundreds of a second or
something and that delay is for many
people like myself something that gives
one terrible motion sickness if there's
a delay like that one's brain gets very
confused and it's it's version of
telling you it's confused its error
message is to make you feel nauseous um
so that's you know it's an issue with
those kinds of things but I think the uh
uh the thing that I'm expecting is that
the sort of Next Generation of augmented
in virtual reality displays it depends s
of how heavy they are to to fit on one's
head eventually they'll get lighter um
but I think the main thing that is
probably true is that they have uh they
will allow one to have very wide angle
of view kinds of displays and one is
going to be able to put you know 10
displays in one's visual field um and
that's you know like I have like
basically four displays on my desk for
instance and and uh if I just had them
virtual sort of all attached to my head
in some very high resolution virtual
reality device I could have 10 displays
in my visual field and that might be a
nice thing it might also be as I say
that people have have chosen to use
smartphones that are a small fraction of
their visual field so I can't completely
say that that will be something that
people will really want but uh I think
there's then the question of of how do
you control all these things and what
can you use and you know we have the
notion of typing we have the notion of
moving a mouse uh there are 3D gestures
one can imagine which have not really
caught on yet they may eventually I I
kind of think that there's a certain
degree of uh this idea of putting your
fingers on keys and the keys are in a
definite place that is a very in a sense
is a very streamlined way of interacting
with with the system if you say well I'm
going to you know do all kinds of weird
hand gestures they're less anchored uh
they're less like oh I'm pressing the
the H key or something um it's like is
there you know is there a key in the air
um I'm not sure whether people learn
well how to do sort of precision motions
um that can convey lots of information
in uh uh just sort of in the air so to
speak but there are many other
possibilities for how that kind of thing
might work now another thing when you
have a virtual reality display there are
questions about well what about you move
your eyes um can you pick things out by
just by moving your eyes could you have
a menu that shows up and if you go move
your eyes to cental on that menu it
means I selected the menu or some such
other thing so these are all things
which I don't think we yet know what
people are going to find Convenient I
mean the fact is that if we look at the
history of user interfaces there are all
kinds of different things that uh have
seemed important and then not seemed
important like oh is it you know do you
hand write on your smartphone surface
that was a thing for a while it turns
out that typing is actually the thing
people prefer even though it's kind of
goofy because you got this tiny keyboard
and you certainly can't use all your 10
finger typing there at least uh young
kids I guess might be able to but but
anybody else their hands are too big and
so you end up doing thumb typing and all
these kinds of weird things which you
know who knew that that would turn out
to be a thing that people preferred to
picking up a sty and drawing things with
handwriting and having the computer
recognize that handwriting so I think
it's it's a um it's slightly difficult
to
predict
uh Rebel is asking was the separation of
matter antimatter proposed by by
feineman or earlier no it was it was
much earlier it was a as soon as
antimatter was known in the 1930s people
started thinking about the possibility
that the Universe might have a bunch of
antimatter in it I think certainly
by
um it
was widely discussed by the
1960s and the main thing that was
imagined was that matter and antimatter
would be kept apart because there would
be any place where they were nearby
there would be annihilation of matter
and antimatter and that would produce a
bunch of radiation a bunch of of photons
and other such things and the pressure
associated with that radiation would
keep the matter and antimatter apart
it's a phenomenon often called lien
Frost phenomenon which is something
where if you have a similar case if you
have a drop of water and it's on a very
hot surface the drop of water will like
skate around skid around the surface
because it's kind of being suspended on
a on a bed of steam because right where
the the water drop kind of touches the
very hot surface that hot surface is
boiling the water into steam right where
it touches and that steam has pressure
that keeps the water away from the hot
surface so it causes that water drop to
just skate around on the surface and
survive much longer than it would given
the heat that's coming from the um uh
the surface and and the other thing to
say is that the steam is kind of an
insulator to heat and so even though
there may be lots of heat coming from
that surface it doesn't Reach the the um
the water drop as much as it would
otherwise and so kind of a hypothesis
was perhaps there will be places in the
universe where matter and anti matter
are held apart by radiation pressure
associated with Annihilation right on
the boundary and we simply don't see
that kind of phenomenon uh in any broad
way in the
universe you know people have looked for
antimatter from other parts of the
universe people have looked for that in
cosmic rays coming from from space
mostly from the Sun but maybe also from
other sources there even was an
experiment on the U International Space
Station looking for um anti-atoms of
various kinds and didn't didn't find a
significant
number uh Brady's asking are there anti-
neutrons anti- elements yes there are
anti- neutrons some some particles like
photons the anti of the photon is just
just a photon but all of the uh quarks
and so-called leptons the electron the
muon the nutrino all those things all of
those things have separate have anti
versions of themselves that are
different from the things themselves um
and uh in fact in in um for both protons
they are antiprotons neutrons there are
anti- neutrons so yes they can be
anti-atoms and people have made um
anti-atoms
up to quite large atomic numbers you
know far down the periodic table you can
absolutely have a I doubt an anti-
uranium atom has ever been made but um
uh in principle you can make um uh
certainly antih
helium has been made I'm not quite sure
how far it's gone um it it is not easy
to do that because you have to kind of
you know get all those antiparticles
sort of cooled down to the point where
they can kind of merge into a nucleus
and that's not so easy to
do
um let's see Paula asks does technology
behave differently depending on outside
factors like atmospheric pressure
temperature gravity is there an ideal
environment that's an amusing question
uh you know when I first had an iPad
right when the iPad came out I left it
out in the sun and it got very unhappy
it has internal temperature sensors that
switch it off when it gets too hot
because the uh circuitry silicon
circuits have
um uh just don't work if they're too hot
so most
um um
Electronics semiconductor Electronics
relies on the fact that the electrons so
so normally in a material well in
individual atoms there are electrons are
just kept sort of trapped within the
atom they just sort of connect you know
the they they they sort of orbit the
nucleus in a sense held in by electrical
forces and they don't escape from their
atoms in a metal atoms are are all sort
of arranged together and the the sort of
electrons from different atoms get
shared and there's What's called the
conduction band where electrons are kind
of free to roam freely around the the
the solid that is the metal and that's
the fact that they roam freely is what
allows is is what allows the conduction
of electricity because conduction of
electricity is just electrons moving
around and in a metal the electrons just
move freely around in a semiconductor
they don't move freely around except
that if you can give them enough energy
they eventually get to the state where
they they they reach the this conduction
band but there isn't there's a there's a
band Gap there's a there's a gap of of
electrons below that energy uh aren't
able to roam freely they're just trapped
within their atoms but as soon as they
have above a certain energy they're able
to roam freely in the material and so
semiconductor devices work by having uh
by by putting voltages and things to
effectively increase the energy of
electrons so that under certain cases in
certain cases they will sort of roam
freely and in other cases they'll be
trapped in an atom and that allows you
to make switches which can be used for
transistors etc etc etc okay here's the
catch the catch is that
uh the if you heat up the material the
electrons will start running around
quickly and effectively have higher
energy anyway independent of all those C
ly arranged sort of voltages that lead
to switches and things like that the
electrons will just be all bouncing
around and they will be moved into the
conduction band and so that means that
that uh something where you have a piece
of electronics it's all based on these
semiconductor switches and transistors
and all that kind of thing you heat it
up and those will all just sort of go
they none of them will work because the
electrons will all be sort of so uh
highy that they will reach this
conduction band and you don't you don't
get the kind of switching capabilities
and so when you make Electronics too hot
um it uh uh it stops working at least
Electronics of the kind we have right
now just stops working when things get
cold the electronics will still work one
of the issues is that if you have uh
sort of joints between things that are
made but with uh uh with soering or or
something like that where you have
different metals that are next to each
other one of the things that will happen
is that well when you when you heat up a
metal or any material actually but
Metals as an example when you heat them
up the atoms
will what does what does the temperature
do the temperature makes the atoms move
around with more energy and kind of
makes them move around faster as you
heat it up most materials expand when
they're heated because the atoms are
jiggling around more and more and so
they can kind of the atoms are all sort
of held together by these forces between
atoms and as you increase the
temperature they sort of the atoms sort
of get get closer and closer to escaping
from those sort of being held together
by those interatomic forces and so what
happens is the material expands because
the atoms are all sort of allow getting
to be on average further apart so most
materials expand when heated contract
when cooled the issue is that different
Metals depending on all of their
different detailed characteristics will
expand at different rates as you
increase their temperature so as you
cool it down one of the things that can
happen is they'll contract but they'll
contract to different Rate rates and the
result of that is you get a crack
between you know one metal kind of
contracts more the other than the other
metal and when they were supposed to be
right next to each other connected that
no longer works the crack forms and your
circuit doesn't work anymore so that's a
thing that tends to limit things on the
on the cold side um and there's kind of
a normal operating temperature I don't
know maybe minus 10 degrees centigrade
to
maybe uh a little bit less than 100
degrees Centigrade I would say 70°
Centigrade or something like that I'm
not sure exactly how much is uh you can
work it out because we know the the band
gap for silicon which is what most
conductors are made of I think it's 1.2
electron volts and I could do a little
calculation but I'm not sure of the of
what temperature that sort of all goes
goes to hell so to speak but anyway so
so that's that's one feature of things
is temperature can affect
Electronics um things like humidity
don't immediately affect Electronics but
eventually if you get water and things
you know spill water on your computer
actually they behave much better on that
these days but in the past the problem
is you spill water on a computer and
lots of things that were supposed to not
uh transmit electricity between them
will start transmitting electricity
water is not a great transmitter of
electricity it's not like a wire or
something made of copper but it is a
somewhat reasonable conductor of
electricity and if you have two
different let's say copper wires that
were initially on something that didn't
transmit electricity at all and you put
water on those two things the water will
allow
some electric current to flow from one
wire to the other which again very bad
for the circuit I mean we kind of know
it's kind of like the uh you know be
careful with electrical devices if
you're hanging out in a bathtub full of
water because you know if the hairdyer
falls in the in the water it it has in
so far as it's uh has electric current
flowing through it that current will
flow through the water and will throw
flow through you and it's very bad for
electric currents to flow through you
why is it bad for electric currents to
flow through you it's because uh
electric uh electricity is what makes
muscles contract and so if you uh and
this was in fact how some electrical
features were discovered um 300 years
ago or so 250 years ago um was uh if you
take a muscle and you sort of put an
electric current into it the muscle will
twitch the muscle will will um uh kind
of uh um because that's the signal that
your your nerve is sending to the muscle
is an electrical signal and there's a
junction neuromuscular Junction between
the nerve and the muscle and it's the
presence of an electrical signal comes
from your brain to the muscle that
causes the muscle to contract and so if
you have an external source of
electricity and it is getting into your
muscles your muscles will contract now
the muscle which is kind of the most
important I suppose for for for all of
us on an ongoing basis is the muscle of
the heart and the really bad thing is if
the the what's happening for the heart
is the heart has a um a nerve uh venal
nerve right it's a nerve that goes
through the center of one's uh of one's
neck as well protected nerve that comes
from one's brain that is kind of giving
the heart a signal to you know heartbeat
heartbeat heartbeat and and the Heart
then responds that the way a heart
actually respond responds it it really
only give needs to be given a little
kick and then the structure of the heart
itself causes it to have this quite
complicated uh kind of contraction
motion and so on um but the problem is
if you
get kind of uh uh if you get an electric
current that gets into your heart so to
speak it will make the heart and the
muscle of your heart contract in a way
that isn't the right way for it to
contract because it's carefully set up
to contract just based on these
particular nerves based on an electrical
signal from these particular nerves and
so that is really bad because it will
cause your heart to fibrillate which
means it's it's kind of just wobbling
around and um responding to electrical
signals uh as a muscle so to speak but
it's not doing that in a nice organized
way where it's it's pumping blood uh
through through you and if it if it
continues to fibrillate and just sort of
wobble around then blood won't get
pumped around your body and that's
that's bad news and that's why for
example a defibrillator is something
where you're putting uh actual
electrical signals through the heart um
in such a way as to get it to kind of
wake up and stop wobbling around
randomly and start beating in its
organized way again but if you get a
electric shock um that uh passes current
across your heart it can be a bad thing
because it can start that fibrillation
process just as a defibrillator can stop
that fibrillation process and so the you
know the rule of thumb for for people is
if you're going to touch something which
is kind of a electrical outlet or
something stick one hand in your pocket
so you only have one hand that is uh uh
that's might get an electric shock and
then the muscles in that hand will
contract maybe that arm and that's
that's that's bad but um it doesn't uh
if you if you have your two hands and
there on different uh you can get an
electric current from one hand to the
other that kind of goes through your
heart and that's that's really bad news
so it's kind of like you keep one hand
in your pocket when when messing with
electrical stuff principle um is is uh
that's why that's worthwhile but okay
that that's um uh but back to how
Electronics Works
um Electronics does not care about
gravity at least not any kind of gravity
that um we typically encounter now
Electronics I suppose the one case is if
you have something in a I don't know in
something which is being rammed into
something at very high speed and it has
a very high deceleration deceleration is
kind of acts like gravity you can't
actually distinguish between if you sort
of have if you're not seeing the outside
world you can't distinguish between pure
acceleration and the result of the force
of gravity that's the so-call principle
of equivalence um that uh but in any
case so sort of gravity of a kind that
we'd find on the earth or something
doesn't affect Electronics in any any
significant way um gravity does affect
or acceleration can certainly affect
things because if you decelerate fast
enough it's mostly mechanical problems
that occur it's mostly sort of wires
will come detached and things will get
sort of physically damaged it's not that
the electronics uh will have uh it's not
anything of internal to the
electronics now I mean there are other
things that happen so for example cosmic
rays high energy particles coming from
the Sun mostly protons uh that hit the
the upper atmosphere of the earth and
most of those things are stopped by the
atmosphere of the earth not much gets
through at sea level it's mostly muons
at sea level um particles that they they
sort of survive a bit further in the
atmosphere um but uh uh if you you go to
a place that's you know uh at a high
altitude like you know Denver or
something like that that's a uh a mile
roughly a mile high then there's less
volume of atmosphere above you and so
the the cosmic gray protons that hit the
upper atmosphere of the earth many more
of them survive to to you to where you
are in Denver let's say then at sea
level and so that has the effect that
when one of those protons goes through a
piece of electronics it leaves a trail
of ionization it leaves a the energy
associated with that high energy proton
for example will rip electrons out of
the atoms that they're in and that will
lead to effects that uh that that that
will sort of change the electrical
electronics of what happens in piece of
electronics a microprocessor or
something like that and so if you have a
memory chip you will routinely get
errors in the memory chip associated
with uh cosmic rays and in fact that's
even used years ago I um late 1970s I I
suggested to people gosh why you know
given that fact that the cosmic rays
lead to errors and memory chips um how
why don't you just use that to detect
particles and uh I think people had
independently figured out you might be
able to do this but at the time people
say oh no no you wouldn't be possible
now uh semiconductor particle detectors
are very very very common it's a very
common way to try and detect particles
but in any case the um uh the thing that
um uh so Electronics memory chips things
like that when there are these particles
coming from cosmic rays they will change
the data that's in um uh uh that's in
these um um uh
um in in these in these bits and um um
that um
um uh so that's that's a that's a sort
of a different effect so so back in the
day this is early 1980s when computers
sort of very high performance computers
were delivered to places uh that were
high altitude particularly Los Alamos
National Lab big uh uh big physics Etc
research organization happens to be at
7,000 ft altitude in in New Mexico and
uh when computers would be delivered
there they would regularly behave
somewhat differently than they did at
sea level as a result of uh cosmic rays
although what what really saved that is
a typical memory chip nowadays and and
semiconductor memories that existed at
that time as well have error correction
so in a in a let's say there's a 32 bit
B of memory actually what's really there
is like 34 or 35 bits and those extra
bits are used to check the other bits
and correct any kind of error that might
arise from from cosmic rays so that's
that's a um uh that's that's kind of a a
thing for that
now there are when you try and use
Electronics in space it's a big mess
complicated because you have lots of
cosmic rays um and uh it's non-trivial
to get the electronics to kind of
survive that you have to kind of Harden
it um and uh it's not even clear in
general how to do that you know if you
have multiple copies of the CPU or
something you can have them kind of you
know at least they won't all be Zapped
at the same time probably and you put
kind of shielding to prevent the cosmic
rays getting to that to your piece of
electronics things like this um the uh
and also the electronics itself can be
made so that it doesn't depend quite it
it requires more of a kick to flip a bit
from a one to a zero and so
on let's
see
uh yes atom comments that deionized
distilled water uh won't conduct or at
least a lot less than ordinary water
this is true um evangelos is asking how
about solar flares how do they affect
technology yeah well um they put lots of
particles actually particularly
electrons I think into um uh uh
streaming towards the earth from the sun
um they uh they have pretty bad effects
on lots of electronics uh particularly
satellites not shielded by the Earth's
atmosphere but even on the earth I think
we talked about this in another one of
these sessions um the uh uh the effect
on the power grid on electric power
lines things like this can be fairly
dramatic I mean the last um uh really
big such thing so-called Carrington
event happened in 1859 when there were
already Telegraph lines and things like
this but not the same kind of dependence
on electrical systems as we have today
and it's an inter in question let's say
what would happen in the event of a
really big solar flare um to all the
electronics that we have one of the
pieces of good news is that the
electrons from the Sun go a lot slower
than photons from the Sun and so we'd
have a day or two of warning probably
that uh you know the the big pile of
electrons are coming our way I think
maybe is it is it a day or is it only a
few hours I'm not sure but there are
satellites there's at least one
satellite that watches the Sun for these
kinds of things I'm not completely sure
what the um uh you know I don't know
quite what happens in in you know what
what's been figured out about what the
warning system looks like I mean it's
kind of one of these everybody's phone
is going to buzz and say a big solar
flare is coming and it's like so what
are you supposed to do about it I think
you switch off electrical systems and
kind of hope for the best and hope that
the amount of induced current in these
electrical wires is not large enough to
independently cause trouble
um uh
let's see I3 is commenting on a Gamay
burst um I was not paying enough
attention to know about saying that the
biggest of all time uh burst I was not
paying enough attention to know about
that I mean Gamay bursts are a
phenomenon seen in distant galaxies and
uh the um I mean there are a variety of
theories but I think some of the
theories have to do with kind of matter
being dumped into uh uh into uh black
holes and things and as before the
matter is kind of swallowed up by the
black hole the gravity of the black hole
makes it swirl around very fast because
because you know things that are in
orbit around the Earth to to maintain an
orbit around the Earth you go and low
earth orbit at about 177,000 miles an
hour to maintain an orbit around the sun
it's um well different speeds but but uh
uh less than 100,000 miles an hour for
sure um to maintain an orbit around a
black hole you have to be pretty much
going at the speed of light and so what
happens is that material that's swirling
in towards a black hole it will kind of
swirl around and it will made to go
extremely fast and when that happens
it's kind of continually being
accelerated as it's held in this orbit
and one of the features of accelerated
charge particles is that they radiate
electromagnetic radiation and in
particular in that case when there's
when sort of quickly swirls in it it
radiates uh intense electromagnetic
radiation and we perhaps see that as a
gamma ray burst um I don't know the
details of that
one uh right we should probably wrap up
soon here
um there's a question here about what
determines the color of a leaf when the
weather changes and I should know the
answer to that I think I did once and I
don't really know I mean
basically these are leaves that are
dying and they the chlorophyll that
makes them green um is somehow breaking
down but I don't know exactly how that
works um and uh ending up with different
colors I mean the fact that chlorophyll
is green is not unrelated to the fact
that it is absorbing photons from the
sun and it is since green is the is the
most is the is the place where there's
sort of the most photons that come from
the Sun that's where uh the the the the
leaves are green because Evolution has
set things up so that uh the one's
preferentially absorbing um is this
right the is this right let me think
about this for a second um when Once to
absorb so that the green light is
obviously reflected from the leaf um so
am I confused here uh red algae which
live under the ocean have you know the
ocean is absorbing
light uh am I getting myself confused I
think it's the case that the red algae
are are red because they only get only
the red light survives at that depth in
the ocean and uh let me think about this
for a second um well in any case the the
the green color is associated with what
the um uh you know what will allow the
the most relevant light from the sun to
be
absorbed
um let's
see oh boy there's a question from gist
could there be nanites waiting for more
favorable conditions to multiply uh Nano
nanosized uh sort of living organisms in
samples we bring back from an asteroid
how can we be sure there aren't any
that's a good question
question uh that's a good question I
mean I think that's kind of like asking
the question
given to know for sure it's like given
this microprocessor does it have some
sort of malicious circuit that's been
burnt into the microprocessor you know
can we tell if the thing is going to do
something bad can we tell if this
particular viral sequence that we could
build into a virus is going to do
something bad bad in humans um I think
it will be pretty hard to tell if
there's a uh particularly if it let's
say there was an alien life form or
something that was on a very tiny scale
but was uh uh when it was as soon as it
was given you know water or something it
suddenly can start to replicate and uh
um and you know it has some complicated
chemistry or something that causes it to
do a perhaps more efficient form of the
replication the biolog iCal cells do um
and could that sort of uh destroy the
Earth or some other bad thing like that
um I think uh um the
um uh I think to be absolutely sure it's
not easy um I think you know it's it's
hard to know things that one doesn't
know things where one you know could
there be a mechanism that would cause
the the asteroid Rock to suddenly start
replicating and doing crazy things in
principle they could be uh is it likely
no it's not likely but you know one
doesn't know for sure it's it kind of
reminds one of the fact that you know
when the first astronauts came back from
the Moon they were quarantined for 10
days or so because people didn't know
whether there might be Moon viruses that
they might have picked up and uh now
that seems kind of absurd but um uh you
know it wasn't it's not self-evidently
obvious um and uh I think you know the
possibility of some sort
of lifelike replicating thing that is
triggered by uh kind of um interaction
with with something different than it's
usually interacted with is an amusing
concept I think not very likely I mean
it reminds me of the movie 2001 of Space
Odyssey which features a um uh um a Big
Slab that's been buried on the moon for
some large number of years which has the
feature that as soon as it sees sunlight
it sends out some intense radio signal
which starts a whole giant plot Arc in
the movie but um uh that was kind of the
the concept that you know the aliens
buried it there and trying to wait until
somebody would notice it had some weird
magnetic feature um by the way there are
magnetic anomalies on both the Earth and
the moon just like in that movie not
known at the time the movie was made but
any case where you kind of find because
it has this weird magnetic feature and
then once it's excavated then the aliens
know some some clever folk were around
on the earth and the moon because once
it's excavated it can see the Sun and do
different things so it kind of wakes up
when it sees the Sun and so I I suppose
the the concept here would be the
nanites wake up when they're brought to
Earth and start eating us which would be
a bad outcome I think
um all right we should probably wrap up
there so thank you for some interesting
questions I see a whole bunch that I
didn't have a chance to get to and uh
I'll look forward to doing this again
another time so thanks very much and bye
for
now